thank you
thank you
we've endorsed JP right JD Mandel
foreign
laughs
knowing
me
[Music]
I have with me David Patman he is a
progressive host
an executive producer of the nationally
syndicated radio and TV program The
David packman show and I wanted to talk
to David packman he is
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about being a beta male and being
an alpha male what are we talking about
here
there are males most men today yeah male
they think and act like a woman they are
emotional they are mentally off they
have no logic
and that's a beta man they go along with
homosexuality hold on Buddy
that's a lot that's a lot we win
everything that's raw abortion they they
can act just like a woman a beta
Marathon
a dozen because he's a logical thinking
and they are controlled by the darkness
of David Patman
years they paid him now
David Patman is
David Patman
he is a failure now
I gave it Pac-Man he is
David Patman he is
[Music]
David Pac-Man is
David Pac-Man years they paid him now
David you're not here to communicate I
really appreciate you coming on I'm
going to let you go it's a waste of time
to talk to you we're not communicating
you're acting like this you're asking
bizarre questions
and you wasting my time I preaching that
I'm coming all right
goodbye
[Music]
all men who are progressive
[Music]
look at those eyes man that that's that
that dude he is gone ladies and
gentlemen Alex Jones is now very very
upset with me look at that that is a
freaking Predator right there he thinks
he's smarter than you think he's better
than you and he's gonna beat you Pac-Man
never talked to the new world war
because Pac-Man's a loser
man's a loser he's not a knight at the
round table that's true I'm not a knight
at the round that that actually is
accurate that dude is gone
telling our children but not to be it's
made
out of here
[Music]
prepare to meet your destiny
[Music]
that is a freaking Predator right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
he's better than you and he's gonna beat
you
mangoes
I love mangoes too
nah now that we are up under our bodies
regime my bag of mangoes now costs
11.99 that seems like a pretty good deal
a bag of mangoes mango or mangoes
that's it eight or eleven bucks
[Music]
pray my man goes back down
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mangoes
Trump was doing this with his personal
toilet but shakes
[Music]
and showers elephants and bathrooms
elephants and bathrooms what on Earth is
going on with Trump toilets
Trump's White House toilet
clogged
clogged clogged
with documents that Donald Trump was
flushing down the toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
[Music]
ten times
[Music]
God bless the United States thank you
very much elements of bathrooms well
welcome everybody it's my uh incredible
pleasure a unique pleasure and I'm
actually saying that seriously I said it
to Michael Knowles when I was on his
show I said it's such such a pleasure to
be here and that wasn't true here it
actually is a pleasure to be with uh all
of you again uh I am on Truth essential
and I am Live on YouTube twitch and
Facebook and I actually if usually
there's really not much to be optimistic
oh am I muted again
[Music]
this is muted
oh damn
hold on
[Music]
weird
oh we're live
um almost always the the worst moment of
any week would be a trump rally but
yesterday was so uniquely sickening at
the National Rifle Association rally
where Trump
mispronounce the names of the victims
from Uvalde Texas and it was a literal
Gong Show they rang a Gong between each
of the names that Trump read and then
Trump danced after
the speech it's it yesterday was so
uniquely sickening it was Pond scum
yesterday there's no I can't think of
any lower moment
um in recent American politics than
yesterday that today might actually be
less overtly disgusting than yesterday
now I'm still open to the idea that
Trump will find some way to make today
even worse like for example Lauren
bobert is in the crowd that's pretty
sickening they might still find some way
but it's likely to be another vomitus
evening and that's a very very sad and
disgusting thing but we're going to be
looking at everything so I'm glad that
you are joining me it appears as though
Trump is on time today yesterday he was
quite literally two and a half hours
late
it's you know Obama yeah we've endorsed
JP right JD Mandel JD Mandel there's a
there's a per sort of like a little up
speak there JD Mandel that that adds to
how crazy that is Trump has already
landed in Casper Wyoming so it's at
least within the realm of possibility
that this event will be on time today
Zach says via Super Chat get Vincent
rack and yellow back on he had a very
interesting point about why he thinks we
need to move on from mask mandates and
focus on vaccines and ventilation very
insightful yeah he already um I mean
we've moved I have I think we're we've
moved on from Mass mandates I'm glad to
have him back on but
it seems uh it seems that people have
indeed moved on uh okay let's get to a
couple of different things one thing is
I I did a segment on this on yesterday's
podcast not everybody has the podcast
it's free I mean everybody should have
it but you know not everybody does and
it's not like it's the uh you know the
bonus show or anything that that uh Alex
Jones dislikes Pac-Man's a loser but
we've been increasingly talking about
this guy Herschel Walker and there's a
very kind of complicated discussion
Herschel Walker is the Georgia Senate
candidate former football player and
he's completely incoherent every time
he's interviewed he he literally cannot
put together a coherent thought
and there's a lot of different kind of
I don't want to say sensitive groups let
me let me think about the right way to
say it there's a lot of different
speculation about why Herschel Walker is
so incoherent and everybody that someone
is taking offense to every single
explanation but I actually think that
there's a bigger issue okay so let me
play these clips for you this first clip
is after we learned about the Uvaldi
Texas shooting
um excuse me CNN's Manu Raju asked
Herschel Walker whether there should be
new gun laws and his response was
completely incoherent okay listen to
this
CNN
are you do you supporting your gun laws
in the wake of this Texas do you support
the new gun laws
okay so he was asked what about new gun
laws and he said I like to see it and
everything and stuff and I don't have
subtitles unfortunately he then the next
day appeared on Fox News and he was
again asked about what might you do
about school shootings and he says he
wants a department that can look at
young men looking at women looking at
social media see there is a person
willing that weapon you know Kane Kia
Abel you know and uh you know that's the
problem that we have and I said what we
need to do is look into how we can stop
those things you know he talked about
doing a disinformation what about
getting a department that can look at
young men that's looking at uh women
they're looking at uh just social media
right his so the idea is make a
department Maybe even an apartment that
can look at young men looking at women
looking at social media Okay so
some people are saying this is mental
illness and it is true that it's been
widely reported that Herschel Walker has
dissociative identity disorder multiple
personalities horrible accusations about
things he he has allegedly done to his
ex-wife or wife or whatever that there's
that it's specifically Mental Illness
but the truth is
most mentally ill people don't have
ideas like this and it seems wrong to
say Herschel Walker is just mentally ill
then the issue of brain injury is coming
up I mean to some degree it sounds like
he has a brain injury he played football
chronic traumatic encephalopathy often
known as CTE is being suggested but our
friend Arian Foster the great former NFL
running back said listen I'm
paraphrasing his perspective but he's
been in the league and around football
players long enough and there's lots of
brain injuries but uh most people with
football brain injuries aren't this
unhinged when it comes to politics and
that so like that's kind of a cop-out as
well and it's sort of offensive to just
say this is merely a brain injury I
don't pretend to know what it is but
what is increasingly shocking to me is
that something is so I mean that he can
barely think okay
and he won his primary
okay Republicans said this is the guy we
want to send to the Senate
or at least to the general election
in uh in November so you know I don't
know I I obviously you all know I don't
want to offend anyone mental illness
chronic trauma uh CTE brain injury I I
don't know he also has terrible
political ideas and I think he's had
those for a very long time I don't know
what one thing we blame but this guy can
barely put together a coherent sentence
um I I don't know and he's in over his
head obviously obviously and over his
head all right so that's my thought on
the Herschel Walker thing and I don't I
don't know what else to say I mean I
don't I don't want to offend anyone most
mentally ill people don't say things
like this most people with brain
injuries don't say such crazy political
things either so I don't know I don't
know what to tell you guys it's bad it's
bad and that's who so of all the choices
that's who Republicans said send that
guy to represent us let's talk a little
bit about what happened yesterday oh
everybody come on in I see all these
people joining us welcome welcome
everybody's welcome here uh thanks to
superfluousification I hope I pronounced
that correctly uh with the 19.99 Super
Chat Dino says sir it appears even
analog machines are implicated in Mike
pillow's lawsuit against all machines
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines my grandfather
clock is currently in a deposition with
Mike pillow's attorney you know this is
a really sad story when Mike pillow
announced the lawsuit against all
machines I assumed that non-electronic
machines would be exempt I have a friend
who's super into making his own corn
tortillas and he gets he has a special
supplier of what's called Nick
stimulized corn and this is like one of
these presses it's almost like a vice
it's table mounted it's completely
manual I mean it's made of heavy metal
and it kind of has a crank where you
compress your Nick stimulized corn and
make your own tortillas even that
machine is now under threat of
defamation suit from Mike pillow so no
machine even the simplest Antiquated a
completely manual machines that require
no electricity no gasoline e even those
are under threat we're doing a class
action lawsuit against all machines it's
crazy it's crazy
okay let's look at a couple of other
things earlier today I sent the
following Tweet now one of the things
I've learned is that there is nothing
you can tweet about that someone won't
have a problem with someone I could say
hey you know what
um
nutrition is good and somebody would go
David
how dare you
are you saying that everyone should have
4 000 calories a day just eating is good
no matter what like now I'm just saying
like you know I don't know nutrition is
good it seems Seems like it's kind of
something you need I don't know there's
nothing you can say on social media that
somebody won't have a problem with and a
lot of people had a problem with this
but that being said I'm going to read it
to you I said when Trump read the names
of the Uvaldi victims at his rally
yesterday it was sort of like when
Mormons baptized non-mormons who have
died against their will forcibly pulling
them into his cult posthumously and it
was fascinating to see a former Mormon
actually reply and say I was able to be
the one performing the baptisms and
reading the names I tried to be as
faithful to the pronunciations I assumed
they were yeah so so a lot of people
saying that's a pretty good analogy
actually uh some people said it was
terrible but as a reminder here's what
that was here was Trump yesterday
reading the names of the shooting
victims and they they rang they're
calling it a bell oh hold on a second
there's someone who's just spamming
David Hackman over and over again in the
chat you're just banned I don't care
you're gone I just don't even have time
for it
um yeah there were people Joy kit on
Twitch says they thought that it was my
sound board where I was adding the gongs
no no no no no this is what they did
yesterday of silence as I read the names
of these beautiful people
all young wonderful lives ahead of them
they're Brave teachers whose lives were
destroyed by and out of control lunatic
now you've got to know going in any plan
that's based on Trump reading names off
of a piece of paper is very risky
so we'll start
Alexandria Rubio Aletha
[Music]
Ramirez
Emery Garza
Annabelle Guadalupe
Rodriguez Eliana
[Music]
Cruz Taurus
Ellie
Garcia
Jacqueline cazarus
Jayla Nicole
siliguro
Kwame Vive come on Jace
love our nurse
Jose
[Music]
Flores
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Salazar okay so I admit I added three of
trump mispronouncing Indian names that's
from when he went to India during his
presidency but it's essentially just as
bad
thank you
McKenna Lee Elrod
My Thai
Rodriguez
okay I think you guys get the picture I
think we can stop with that and if you
were to not find this to be completely
sickening and you found it genuine in
some way
Trump finished the event by dancing
okay
so this solemn terrible event
Trump danced
see that
oh wait people are saying the last name
was a good okay let's continue then
Miranda I don't remember which names he
screwed up the most yes
Nevaeh Bravo
rojillo Torres
Tess Marie Mata
oh Zia
Garcia
I can think of no
way to turn this tragedy into more of a
joke than to have Trump mispronounce the
names with a Gong after each name like
it you could if you said to me how can
we most do a disservice to the victims
of this it would be
talk about everything other than guns as
a Cause
and then hand Trump a piece of paper to
have a mispronounce the names and ring a
Gong after each name it would be this
Javier
Lopez
two great and beautiful brilliant
teachers Eva Morales
Irma oh God and then the whole the gong
was mistimed then
and thank you very much okay and then
moments later Trump was dancing
so after the very very solemn moment
uh yeah
it's completely nuts one other moment
here Trump trump seems to not really
remember when Trump said he thinks you
need a photo ID to buy cereal at a
grocery store
um oh yeah there's a lot of light hold
on let me see what I can do about that
we're having a bit of an issue
yeah well we'll deal with that in a bit
anyway Trump seems to not understand how
anything works
so important
in addition classroom doors should be
hardened to make them lockable from the
inside and close to Intruders now
correct me if I'm wrong
don't classroom doors already locked
from the inside or is that a thing where
you're not I mean I don't even I don't
even know uh hold on let me see if I can
deal with the light so this would be my
left light
we're at 60. let's see if I can bring it
down to 40.
oh I almost don't even need it yeah okay
actually you know what I think I'm gonna
do I'll keep it at 60 but just turn it
off for now there we go that's much
better that's much better anyway I
didn't I thought school doors already
locked from the inside but I don't know
I mean it I don't it's just it's all
very very strange
so that was that uh as we are standing
by here or dot you can't lock them due
to being an exit for a fire no but what
I'm saying is
you you guys I don't I'm not a locksmith
but there's these locks where you just
push you push the little lock thing so
from the inside either way you're just
turning the knob down and it opens it's
it's just it's locked from the inside so
you can't open it from the outside
I don't understand how that would be
anyway he seems to have no idea how
anything Works
um Chandler Davis says will Donald Trump
speak about Ulysses again probably
David it blows my mind after two plus
years of bashing teachers that
Republican members have the gall to
suggest they should carry guns masks
traumatize children but Terminator
teachers won't how do these people sleep
at night yeah no I've said this before
they've spent two years saying hey
um teachers are critical race Theory
teaching incompetent indoctrinators who
shouldn't be
um trusted with anything
but we should give them all guns and put
them in charge of security right like
but you said these were the incompetent
people what are you what are you talking
about it doesn't make any sense
you're absolutely correct
I don't know if you've seen But Trump is
charging fifteen thousand dollars for
the for a photo op at this rally it's in
my hometown I pray none of the people I
know get swindled yes let us pray for
them okay let me say thank you to a few
people who have just popped in first let
me thank everybody who has grabbed the
twitch Prime subscription today that
includes life is good and Polo Dal mazic
and spycatcher Jen here and Dustin D
colors ATK and irie man that puts us at
eight also some beautiful people oh hold
on a second
some beautiful people have uh signed up
on my website as well I want to say
thank you to Marissa pepper Julie Wright
rot Philip kazanotti and Leslie Arnold
for signing up on my website
joinpakman.com that puts us at 12 and
then also a big thank you to Ryan Gunter
who just gifted a membership on my
website number 13 we'll give that away
at the conclusion of today's stream all
right let's look at a couple of other
things people asking if I'm still
posting on Truth Central I am still
posting on Truth Central I am d Pacman
on Truth Central I basically just repost
my tweets here for now and just see if
anybody gets triggered by them and
sometimes they do let's just see the I
mean the funny thing is it's mostly my
existing followers who are following me
on here but uh
let's see here
yesterday I posted this Ted Cruz NRA
speech is one of the most dangerous and
unhinged speeches I've ever seen in the
entire time I've been covering politics
Troth Central said I have a feeling
he'll be one up by the mango Menace
shortly
then you haven't covered enough politics
oh yeah there's some pretty serious
right-wingers here
Man Truth is crazy
let me see if my if I have my glitches
here
where the hell is truth
here it is truth essential yeah
anyway it's completely toxic but if you
want to join me on Troth Central I'm
just de-pacment on there not not a big
shock as far as uh as far as that's
concerned
okay
um
Ali prugar says did you see my email
about the soundboard no unfortunately we
get so many emails I can I barely see
any emails
uh it's sad but I did get Trump's new
phrase from yesterday virtue cycling
virtue cycling yeah Trump meant virtue
signaling but said virtue cycling our
friend's small fuzzy Moss uh got me that
all right let's look at some clips from
outside the rally from what I've been
told it's pretty aggressively weaponized
here's Lauren bobert wearing what seems
like a parody-sized Maga hat says
um how Trump shared popcorn with her son
I want to tell you a story about his
generosity about how kind he is about
how welcoming he is the things that
these folks write where is her head
that's very strange here in the back
never let anyone see
[Applause]
fake media is the virus
by the way it's only right-wing media at
these events
[Applause]
[Music]
and even not liking germs president
Trump shared a bowl of popcorn with my
14 year old son
wow now listen Wyoming
I know where he's been I don't share
food with my son
but president Trump welcomed him and
engaged with him and showed him love and
respect just like I've seen him do with
hundreds and thousands of other people
all throughout America because he's not
a politician he's a family man he's a
businessman and he loves you he loves
America and he will be back again
[Applause]
um
really wacky stuff huh
uh let's see what else we've got from
the rally
here she was interviewed and said she
wants to arm teachers oh man the left is
completely
they're not politicizing
talk a little bit about the Second
Amendment rights on stage just kind of
recap that sure well the answer to
Uvalde and what happened there is not to
restrict law-abidings gun owners and and
what they can carry
um I I got into this because I
challenged fatal O'Rourke and I told him
hell no you're not going to take our
guts right and and now here he is again
trying to get politically famous on the
grades of children and uh so we have
Solutions we can secure our schools we
can make sure our children are safe we
can certify and arm our teachers we can
have armed security in certify in the
schools but the response that we're
hearing about in ubalde is unacceptable
I just realized how hilarious the
framing of this is she's like literally
a foot lower than this guy especially if
it's true that shots were fired before
the gunman entered the school there was
plenty of time to neutralize this threat
but this is why gun free zones are
deadly they're proven to be deadly and
I'm pretty sure this rally is a gun-free
zone shocked that she be willing to be
there you know that's that's pretty
surprising seems pretty dangerous
um
let's see what else we have
oh wait a second Bernie threw a pitch
this I have to see
whoa
that's a pretty good toss I have to say
I like that Bernie with a little a
little spin on there was that the circle
change
[Applause]
thank you
I might have to take back my commentary
that Bernie shouldn't run that would
that was pretty serious I have to tell
you
uh okay let's see if there's anything
else from the rally
okay that's old actually yeah we may not
have that much more from the rally which
is probably a good thing to be perfectly
Frank
um we're keeping an eye on uh Trump uh
scheduled to show up any minute now
about uh 20 20 minutes or so okay very
good well we got that
um super chats are dumping dumping
dumping in which is crazy
um and I'm gonna read some of them here
let's see what we've got
uh
what do we have here
okay
you can't handle the truth no certainly
I can't David love your show wanted to
say sky news UK is actually a center
News Network yeah I I've gotten about
200 emails about this I mistakenly uh I
confused Sky News Australia with Sky
News UK
um and I apologize for that I did make a
mistake I like the GOP like to use
Chicago for pro-gun propaganda but don't
the northeastern states have strictest
gun laws and least amount of gun deaths
compared to other regions in the U.S I I
haven't looked at that data super
recently but yes I believe uh I believe
that that it that remains the case I
believe that remains the case
David former teacher in our building the
doors could only lock from the outside
to prevent teacher abusive students oh
that's interesting so which is it are
teachers groomers or should the doors
lock from the inside yeah you've got to
kind of decide
yeah
would you rather have dinner with Beau
bear or Marjorie Taylor green and what
food
um I don't know I guess I'd rather have
dinner with
Bo bear or Taylor green
I guess Bo bear I don't even know why
quite frankly
so they lock the doors and Shooters hit
the playground at recess yes that's also
been been brought up
thank you David for putting your health
and well-being on the line to cover this
event yeah thank you Chris I appreciate
that
um very very powerful stuff let me say
thank you to Jason sickmeyer Tommy
horsewill and Philip kazanotti they've
each gifted a membership on my website
putting us at 16 we will gift those
three memberships
um at the end of the Stream
that'll be
very very important very very important
let's listen to a couple of voicemails
yeah lots of voicemails coming in right
now
I did just wondering if we should be
worried about lawsuits for any of our
our comedian simple machines you know
levers pulleys inclined planes pulleys
are done under Mike pillow's lawsuit for
sure okay people calling in about uh
Herschel Walker
yes uh I'm just commenting on the
Herschel Walker
comments you know if he's going to run
for Senate
there should be some sort of minimum uh
IQ test or some sort of uh
cognitive tests for senators I mean who
cares if he's had brain injuries I got
hit by a car shattered my uh helmet I've
had brain injuries I've uh I got sent to
a psych board for some miscommunication
somebody thought I was suicidal and
they'd uh petitioned me to go I was not
but I had to stay there for three days
and most the people in there are just
talking about their meds and swishing
them around and a lot of the nurses and
doctors they're just as crazy as anybody
else
and if you're taking uh the
consideration that we've had uh threat
of nuclear war for over 50 years of
course most people are kind of crazy
most Americans are kind of crazy with
the personalities if you listen to uh
Alan Watts or ROM dosser it kind of
delves into all right well that's
getting that's getting pretty pretty
deep there
um um okay let's see what else I've got
as far as um as far as voice I actually
don't have that much in terms of
voicemails right now
hey David
um I'm literally watching an rsbn live
stream right now I don't know if you're
uh doing anything today but if you would
love to Enlighten us with your presence
I sure would enjoy it because this looks
like a train wreck my friend yeah oh
it's so enjoyable to watch uh yeah I
didn't know if you knew it was going on
you know what we can actually do let's
go back a little bit earlier into their
stream and just listen not that message
he was coming I got a motel there was no
way I was going to miss this not on
Earth I was gonna miss this day what is
it about President Trump that inspires
you to come out here be so energetic and
positive and you know wait what how many
hours early are we right now six hours
early right now there's only one thing I
can say America First America First he's
the only person to put America First did
y'all did you know any of these people
or do you come alone no I came with my
family here we are
very cool yeah we had to come up here we
had to these are new people I've never
met before and we've become family all
of a sudden like literally family
oh I love I love get her she was saying
she watched me on get her some of y'all
are probably watching rsbn stream live
on getter right now so if you are shout
out to all of you that's g-e-t-ttr check
them out I want to talk to all you guys
literally I have like two hours to kill
out here so I I think the dear God the
purpose of like being out here before
the rally starts is to get to know who
these people are who the Patriots are
out here before the rally shirts people
that you know the left in the media and
celebrities they all ignore so kind of
the people that keep this country
running yeah
Direction so we'll start who's talkative
all of you all right we'll start here
where's your what's your name where are
you from my name is Sarah and I'm from
Casper Wyoming Casper Wyoming so this is
your this is your Turf yes ma'am
absolutely have you ever been to an
event here quite a sociological
experience here or before at the Ford
Event Center yeah
yeah huge Staple in the community and
it's so awesome to see Trump come here
and there's makes us feel really special
what's the inside venue like what can
people expect to see when they get in
there later today lots of stairs
um the floor area is pretty big oh that
may not be good for some of the people
I'm seeing walking around in the
background I hope they have elevators
too um there's a lot of seats going
[Music]
on larger cities oh isn't that the best
this is a relatively small venue you're
not supposed to say that that you're not
that never never ever say that and I'd
like to Denver things like that yeah
I think you can fit 10 000 people in
there how many people do you think are
gonna show ten thousand here we go up
Jay free present job you think it's
gonna be ten thousand or more well how
could there be more that they're only
the max is 10. less I think there's
already at least you know 10 20 000
people here it's amazing like you could
very well be right I haven't moved very
far back but I can't see the end of the
line yet so
it starts and it's like there are so
many people here and it's wonderful
seeing all these people coming out to
support Trump support our country now
who did you come with today I
like a dad
my grandma my mom
and I've been here since 8 PM yesterday
at 8pm yesterday where did you sleep I
didn't sat in my chair in line all night
long
I'm shocked I just have to sleep so much
all the time I think something might be
wrong with me right well that's
incredible we met someone over there
these are the front row Joe's they go to
every single rally
why they're wild they got here Tuesday
one of them got here as early as Tuesday
so would you do it again so far all
right so that's these people let's see
if they talk oh hold on at one point
looks like pillow showed up look at this
let's see let's listen to this we're
doing a class action lawsuit against all
machines so
you're kidding
I love it
let him hi Mike how are you doing all
right okay my brother has my cell phone
and I can see like my phone vibrating
and I'm like you guys but I knew you
were here because the crowd went wild I
said that's what if
I I don't even know what to say about
this I mean it's just crazy
[Applause]
two men when I turn around I'm either
gonna see Donald Trump behind me or
Michael
Glendale it's actually your quote she
made this shirt right on right on
absolutely and where we're at everybody
it's a good time to announce to the
country right here on rspn and uh
hopefully we're gonna bring speech too I
know they've been trying to get a hold
of everybody if you're out there oh
Frank Beach if you're watching call
James okay you have my brother's number
call what a mess huh
but everybody
selection
selection you guys selection code this
movie trailer is out today the
president's gonna show it here at the
rally a real present remember when I say
that oh my God these people they're
really sick a real president uh
selectioncode.com you all go there now
you need to share this trailer
everywhere the moment I didn't realize
is Casper Wyoming is 5100 feet of
elevation so Trump could be noticeably
short of breath today that would be
interesting to see important days at
that I believe ever coming up to save
our country July 16th and 17th and
you're all going to see that go to
selectioncode.com this movie shows that
it's the Tina Peters story but it's also
America's story about we've got now we
know what's inside the machines and uh
it's over
you know we opened them up and they were
filled with almonds and I just don't
know why salted roasted almonds just
every single machine filled with it for
them that's esns Dominion smart mag it's
over we have to terminate the machines
and we are going to do it and it's
amazing when you see this we're doing a
class action lawsuit against all
machines and by the way everybody Tina
Peters is on her way here she's I just
saw we were talking with the President
yesterday I was she's going to be
speaking from the stage if you all know
Tina Peters do you all know Tina I think
she was recently arrested right she's
gonna be here speaking from the main
stage she's a hero she's a hero she's a
gold star mother and her son five years
ago this day died okay on this Memorial
weekend and they uh and so she's going
to be speaking and this story that comes
out of Colorado will actually
um it's a it's a you know it's over a
year now when she uh just come
completely I can't tell if he's out of
breath or losing his train of thought or
both just gotta watch the trailer this
movie's by Lara Logan
Laura Logan's out of her mind completely
out of her mind
just amazing I haven't seen the movie
yet uh it comes out like I say worldwide
debut on July 16th but you gotta share
the trailer and I'm here today getting
the word out there we've gotta uh we're
in this state here uh obviously we've
got to get rid of Liz Cheney right we
got to get rid of this Genie I guess if
there's anyone that knows about election
fraud and people that have gone against
President Trump that's you you've also
been supporting him since day one so
what is Liz Channing the reason you're
here today as well what does it mean to
have someone like her in the Republican
Party well what what I've said everybody
I've said all right well that's what
that's what happened earlier and um so
now we're back back to live David do you
think Mike pillow's manufacturing
equipment is included in his lawsuit oh
yeah I'm sure
the machines were full of tiny Oompa
Loompas changing their votes we are
suing all Oompa Loompas we're doing a
class action
all machine Chris says this sucks I
don't have my phone or computer because
of Mike's lawsuit yeah it's everybody's
just losing losing machines left and
right as a result of it
um
let's look at the trailer for this movie
he's talking about selection code let's
just I'm just curious let's just see
what the deal is
into Mesa County Clerk Tina Peters
alleged body machine security breaches
continues if I asked you this question
oh God thank you
before the 2020 election
[Music]
are these voting machines secure
I would have said yes and after the
election
I would have Lara Logan is a joke who's
recently been uh repeating anti-semitic
conspiracy theories she seems completely
off the rails said yes what changed
she brought in a consultant to make a
forensic copy of the Dominion voting
system in Mesa County
I continue to think that our voting
machines are too vulnerable voting
machines in Georgia and Texas switch
votes from one candidate to another
virtually every machine was broken into
recording machines voting machines did
they say phallic recording machines
voting machines sorting machines
machines machine machines machines
machines which are vulnerable to being
hacked there is no serious person out
there who would suggest somehow that you
could even rig America's elections we've
seen no evidence that any of our voting
systems have been tampered with the
November 3rd election was the most
secure it was the most secure most
secure election in American history
period
the process is okay so to the person
who's just been sending literally 20
messages saying David packman you just
got doxxed if that really happened and
you're actually concerned the right
thing to do would be to email us and let
us know the information rather than than
putting 20 messages on Reddit okay so
like if you're being serious and that's
true
then please just email info
davidpackman.com but just pasting it
again and again and again in the chat
come on guys okay please just email in
if that's the case Okay info
davidpackman.com with a link very
secretive these machines are built by
private companies which we don't have a
right to know that goes on inside those
what did you see during the software
update we've uncovered something that
they're afraid of we didn't consider the
machine the information found there is
the Rosetta Stone they made a mistake
they left the evidence in the machine
and you can hide it as well it's only
what the programmer tells it to say it's
literally like the difference between
going from pickpocketing to credit card
fraud all right well as usual a lot of
claims being made without a lot of
evidence uh being being presented there
man that is um
that is just wild okay uh other super
chats coming in
oh my God not even like one week ago my
sister and dad told me Mike pillow's a
good guy I'm baffled by this BS how do
we reprogram this thought process thanks
for all you do David yeah it's uh it's a
real mystery
we need a general strike our votes
aren't enough to motivate our lawmakers
to actually work for us I've talked
about General strikes before in fact I
would uh I have a number of different
videos about that
um yeah that's I listed it along with a
number of other non-violent protest
techniques and uh you can absolutely
find more about that on my YouTube
channel I want to say thank you to Billy
Carpenter oceanova Cody the epilepsy
Dragon dirt nap stuck a duck and chicken
marsala for the twitch subscriptions
putting us at 22. I also want to say
thanks to Fabio borzada who just signed
up on my website joinpakman.com number
23 today and also a big thank you to
Wesley Taylor for gifting three
memberships at joinpakman.com we'll give
those away that puts us at 26. we're
going to be hearing from Donald Trump
momentarily we've we've had uh bad
thunderstorms all day I think they
started in Jersey and then came up into
New York
um we had some flicker earlier I hope
that we don't have any power issues or
Internet issues during the remainder of
the stream I would absolutely love love
love for you to uh sign up at
joinpakman.com today we have a fantastic
membership discount code that code is
sad Trump you can type it in and then
it's shocking what it will do to these
memberships okay if you prefer you can
also use the code Obama
okay that's also fantastic our number
one funding source is actually those
memberships and I will thank every
single person who gets a membership uh
we do a lot of different things for our
members including providing a priority
call-in feed when we do our town halls
the shows available to you everyday
commercial free six hours before anybody
else gets it
um lots of great things including the
world famous bonus show which Alex Jones
hates okay if Alex Jones hates something
it at least makes me wonder is that
something we should look at very
strongly
okay let me um let me put it that way
let's see what else
um
what else do we have here
Tim Poole posted your contact info I'll
email it to you I wanted to get your
attention where did Tim Poole do that
that would be a really strange thing for
Tim Poole to do
um
anybody know if that's true
Temple posted my contact info
on Reddit
I mean listen Tim pool's done a lot of
stuff but that's
a little hard to believe that he would
do
um if someone can email me whatever the
Tim pool thing is that would be really
great
okay
uh what else do we have going on here
David sir was the election stolen by the
machines or the mules
yeah it's hard to tell at this point
could have really been either
quite frankly
thank you to Jason sick Meyer
as well as Wesley Taylor for gifting two
more memberships numbers 27 and 28.
uh very much appreciate that we'll give
those away a little bit later
um voicemail yeah I've got a couple
other voicemails let's listen to what
we've got
hi David I was I was curious about
um what they really really want to do
with the whole door thing
because it doesn't really seem just like
an applicable idea but what I was
thinking was
um maybe build like hallway doors the
same way they have floodgates so that
possibly if there's an active shooter
roaming the Halls um they can actually
maybe have some sort of gate that traps
the shooter in the hallway
or cast the shooter out of the hallway
for instance okay so I would like to
know your thoughts on that
um thanks Dave
yeah I mean listen I'm not against
anything at its face like I'll think
about whatever like arming teachers okay
I thought about it doesn't make any
sense
but there also has to be some element of
dealing with the guns
I mean I just you're not dealing with
the guns I don't know what you're doing
so uh
we kind of need an all of the above
approach is the way I would put it
18 year olds should not be able to buy
high-capacity weapons absolutely
absolutely all of those things are
completely true
um okay
other voicemails let's see
David
thank you for giving us two days of
awesome streams we need an uncharged
pickle specification I actually I don't
think I have it anymore on my soundboard
another voicemail
David Casey from Oklahoma City about
Walker and Georgia I think he was not
subject to any debates with other
candidates and so I think that's a
strategy against or not where the
Republican party is just not going to
debate so they were not going to hear
what he has to say against the
Democratic candidates
and that's how they're going to elect
them they're just they're just gonna
vote down ballot and he's going to get
elected and it doesn't matter because
he's not going to be debated
uh I I think we have to wait and see
what exactly happens there what's
happening at this rally by the way as a
general
turnaround time on some of this is
pretty short but that's what's going on
in Pennsylvania and of course Doug
mastriano
wow what a what a bizarre event that's
going on
um very strange very very strange stuff
happening there
uh let me say thank you to elodie taggio
Monte as well as
Leonardo katzone and Occam's taser all
three of whom just grabbed memberships
on my website a numbers 29 30 and 31. I
really appreciate that
um
also thanks to Two Fat Matt Monger
poutine
tecolote and Billy Carpenter for the
twitch Prime subscriptions putting us at
35 appreciate that as well
let's continue hearing from people via
voicemail for a little bit expecting uh
Trump any moment here
I think that this is Rebecca from Texas
um
I'm calling in regard to the Uvaldi
shooting
um
I have worked in child protective
services for Texas I only worked
for Texas for about two years and ncps
as an investigator for one year
and
the things that I saw I had to leave I
had to take months off for my mental
health after seeing what I saw
um
honestly I just I feel like the system
failed
all of those children and
including
including the perpetrator
um
he was a child only two weeks ago even
in the state of Texas if he would have
been removed from his home he would have
had him in placement in
um or in custody for those two weeks he
was a child
um and I just feel like
the system failed him on so many levels
and I wanted to ask you I know this is a
big a big
big problem
but
I truly feel like if Social Services was
given the funding that it needs
to help the community
then we maybe could have avoided this
this trial yeah I mean that's a that's a
general statement that's true I outlined
10 specific things I would do as far as
gun laws go and several of them deal
with Community involvement and so-called
mental health uh that would have
specifically impacted at least
potentially impacted this particular
shooter being able to get the guns that
he did so no shortage of ideas as far as
that goes absolutely
okay
um I want to say thanks to Laszlo
zakovitz for signing up today at
joinpakman.com uh Laszlo is today's
newest member on my website number 36
very very much appreciate that Mike
pillow as you can see is now in the
crowd taking pictures with people and
just a lot of uh really really wild
stuff going on there as you can see
um let's see what else
we have here as far as voicemails go
all right David
um just curious here like millions of us
are wondering
um where was the Uvalde school resource
officer why was he not on campus
um we've had I only I've only heard one
report and that he was somewhere off
sleeping in his car yeah I I actually
did not hear the sleeping in the car
thing I heard off campus
or away from the school I just don't
know that we definitively know right now
I mean if if there's a some if there's a
definitive thing about it then by all
means
um
I want to hear about it but I just am
not I don't know that we've definitively
heard and so I want to be careful about
you know I don't know I just I just am
not sure
um Alex says David my Chipotle chili
peppers leaves are turning black is that
bad or is that natural I have no idea I
have never grown Chipotle chili peppers
so I quite frankly could not tell you
anybody in the chat know Chipotle chili
pepper should the leaves be black
very hard for me to say
here is a caller from country code 57
let's see 57 country code let's see what
that is
Colombia okay
hi David I'm fairly new to your show uh
but I find it most interesting and I I
think uh maybe I'm wrong but I think for
a change I agree with the right
this is not a gun problem this is a
psychological problem so anyone who
wishes to purchase a gun should have to
have a psychological evaluation yeah
done
no more than 30 days before the purchase
okay yes uh that's that's an idea it's a
reasonable idea for sure
um there are people emailing me saying
David I would like a free membership
you don't get one by emailing if you
want a free membership just go to
davidpackman.com free membership that's
the only place where you can request a
free membership any other place it's
going nowhere you have to sign up it's
it's obviously free to request a free
membership davidpackman.com
slash free membership okay that's what
it's got to be
um let's see what else we have here
a couple other voicemails
Dave you know I love you right
there is NRA convention in taxis
and there was also another
well-publicized
situation that happened in Texas
so the NRA the National Rifle
Association you know the the association
for firearms tobacco explosives
alcohol and you know to to kind of the
ACF
they banned
firearms from the firearm convention
yeah I mean technically they just banned
it from Trump's speech specifically as
my understanding but obviously the point
is the same one which is
if there's no safer place than the place
with the most guns
it would follow that the way to keep
Trump the safest would be to have him in
a room with tons of guns I don't know
what the ATF stuff is about but
um it yeah it's it's not it's not news
and uh A lot's going on there A lot's
going on there for sure I want to say
thanks to Gary Warner Gary Warner just
signed up at joinpakman.com and his new
member number 37 also want to say thank
you to mija lepay who is new member
number 38 today
feel free to sign up on my website
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code sadtrump if you like you can use
the coupon code Obama Obama if you
prefer it's really up to you you can use
no coupon code at all I don't mind one
way or the other it's completely up to
you
other super chats coming in no okay fair
enough
no super chats there we'll do a couple
oh hold on I'm being told that there's
some new videos
from the rally let's see if that's the
case
Lauren bobert calls the primary
challenge a distraction let's see but
[Music]
but I'm just fine
um but you know these These are
distractions that are in the way the
primary is a distraction she wants to
flop extra covid funds that were sent to
schools this nation why can't we spend a
billion dollars and and increase the
infrastructure of our schools well we
sent 190 billion dollars to our schools
in the name of coven and they're still
unspent money I want that money back by
the way the president talked about it
last night at the NRA convention he
wants that money back yes absolutely yes
he wants the money back Trump's not even
president what's what on Earth could
Trump possibly do about that money it
doesn't make any sense
just makes no sense whatsoever
um okay
new voicemail
tell me this sir
Ted Cruz would rather Implement people
control than gun control
doors
armed guards at doors single points of
Entry
these people would rather
restrict our movement
than guns
they would rather do anything
other than deal with guns it's not just
they would rather restrict movement they
would rather do anything other than
actually deal with guns in any kind of
real way
um thank you to Joseph Pierce who just
gifted a membership and his new member
number 39 today will give that
membership away uh later on we'll we'll
we've been emailing people
um with the free memberships and I think
we've given away I think it's over 350
at this point to be perfectly Frank oh
and Wesley Taylor also gifting one more
that's number 40 today appreciate that
very very much Wesley and lastly thanks
to PC hippie for the twitch Prime
subscription uh Donald Trump scheduled
four minutes ago uh arrived by playing
reportedly an hour ago so that should
not at least be a reason for any kind of
hold up today
um but uh it's anyone's guess when he
will actually come out let's listen and
see what's going on here
um you know just like Mike Lindell said
earlier I I just don't know if I can
trust anything coming out of that state
I really I mean
is it possible to win there
certainly questionable I still I mean
regardless the only way to guarantee
that you lose is to not vote yeah that's
not with that being said you know
continue to get on vote but it's okay to
have your concerns as we continue to
navigate through these murky Waters yeah
and one conversation I had on the plane
this lady was from California and she
asked me who who she thought the uh
nominee would be for the Democratic
party in 2024 oh and she said uh do you
think Joe Biden is going to run again I
was like well that's a big hell no on
that he's not gonna do it neither will
come out
I've said this over and over again Liz
and I I could be wrong and maybe I just
I really think Gavin Newsom is going to
be your nominee for 2024. he can barely
remain Governor well he's not he's not a
very liked person in California but that
doesn't matter if he's light he's got a
he come from a big state of California a
very Progressive State uh he's got the
ties That Pelosi he's got all the deep
deep darts uh he's uh evil you know yeah
I mean but he's got the he's got the
establishment uh Democrats in there I
don't know
Young
can you say charismatic he's not he's
not curious about it he looks like an
evil villain in a movie like that the
guy and Spider-Man that owns the
billionaires
the Democrats have that they could push
forward I mean for for the love of God
Kabbalah Harris didn't even get two
percent of the votes for the Democratic
party when she was running for president
so and I think for the most part they
selected her as it did let's just check
the box it was a box like this seems
really mean I've heard Pete put a judge
just because we want to have the first
openly game there uh yeah mayor Pete
would be the first president the
Democrats do though Liz they just want
to check boxes off yeah his identity
politics at its finest it doesn't matter
if the person has you know what's funny
they have a very specific brand of
identity politics they do
um but they never
um they they just they just don't call
it that
they they
have a neo-reactionary identity politics
which I've talked about before but they
just go oh identity politics is bad well
you guys do it too you don't need
anything else no no if you just yeah you
know what maybe we should all just well
not even say that our chat will go crazy
but you can identify what everyone
identifies because I identified male I'd
actually I'm more likely to get the job
all right you're just now joining us
we're live here in Casper Wyoming at the
Wyoming Center waiting for president
Donald J Trump to take the stage really
any minute now I mean we're we're past
the uh T-minus six minutes
if we're in the game of soccer are we on
the bonus time right now is it called
bonus time if you're watching soccer and
it goes past the time so now we're in
bonus time right now we're we're plus
they call it stoppage time not I I guess
soccer is not exactly their area of
expertise I think we can say okay super
chats are dumping in let's listen I'm
sorry voicemails
hi David Tina here
um
so I've always wanted to ask you
um
so since Trump's base is supposed to not
be the majority of Republican
constituents
why do you feel like
um Republican politicians like Senators
Governors why do you feel like they just
they just can't explain to their
constituents you know why Trump is bad
why his policies are bad
and explain to them like this is not the
person that we should be following he's
not a leader it's it's like we're you I
it's such a it's such an obviously
logical thing
what the caller is saying
these are not people you can talk to in
that way it's just there's you keep this
it's not uh it just it just doesn't work
it doesn't work it's sad I wish it were
different
hey Dave I'm from Oklahoma we have gun
shows like once a month if not
more often uh where anybody just walk in
and walk out again yep
um I was just wondering has there ever
been like shooting it at one of those
places like I can can't imagine one
person firing off a shot and everybody
there's got guns they turn around and
everybody's got guns start shooting each
other
I just wondered if you had any uh
thought on that I I mean it's an
empirical question have there been
shootings at gun shows
um I don't know I I've never looked it
up I mean it would be interesting to
look at I don't know
um
I I will investigate it sounds like an
interesting question
David rumor has it uh this is breaking
news
this came from Mike pillow that this
crowd is better than Woodstock they're
looking at 500 000 people just see the
people oh this looks like a million
person crowd to me this actually seems
like the real million Mega March
I've never seen a crowd like this I
don't know about you guys
guy with the hair says the right claims
the left is trying to take away their
guns while simultaneously trying to take
away our fundamental right to our
machines we're doing a class action
lawsuit against all machines all right I
have a bunch of memberships to give away
Joseph Pierce
Wesley Taylor Kyoko awaya has gifted two
and Wesley Taylor another one that's
five more gifted memberships thank you
so much I think we might be getting
close to 400 memberships total gifted
really appreciate that also want to say
thanks to David Wharton who just signed
up at joinpakman.com and his new member
number 47 today also over on Twitch
thanks to Uncle let's just say uncle
just to keep it uh to keep it PG-13
thanks to Uncle new member number 48
today very much appreciate that
hey David that's Colin I'll have to let
you know this gun control thing all that
we're you know putting doors up and all
this other crap and all that is is a
bunch of cut up that's just it uh the
only thing and all that you can do and
all that to stop this gun violence is to
start putting legislation down for guns
you know
um if you look at Ted Cruz and you look
at his campaign he is the highest paid
Congressman in well Ted Cruz is a
senator and I thought it was Mitt Romney
who actually had received the most
donations from the NRA but the specific
numbers don't even really matter I mean
I think the point is a good point there
other super chats coming in Candace
Owens Tim Scott Herschel Walker always
mentioned their black conservatives
Republicans that they are black
conservatives Republicans but apparently
that's not identity politics Fair
uh Trump I am will to answer any logical
question you have as a trump supporter
if you really want to know why we
support him if you truly want to know
sure well I mean listen here's just like
a basic question about Trump trump says
okay here's my question to this user
Trump promised to build a wall across
the entire U.S Mexico border in his
first term
he didn't do it and he fraudulently
claims it was three weeks away from
being done are you willing to say that
that is completely untrue that he added
a few miles and that it is completely
untrue that he was three weeks away from
finishing the wall I would love to hear
that
just admit that that's a total lie tell
me you still like him
and oh right and that Mexico would pay
for it they paid for nothing
I would love to hear a super chat from
you just saying hey you know what
that wasn't true that didn't happen
Trump didn't do it
failed promise lap didn't LAPD didn't
wait for backup to take on two heavily
armored men when all the had was just
handguns
okay I'm not going to click on that
right now that sounds a little risky
here's five dollars for your espresso
machine's legal defense fund keep up the
good work and retain Council yeah I'm
actually getting Johnny Depp's Attorney
Ben Chu is going to be representing my
espresso machine and then the other
attorney Camille Vasquez is going to be
representing my milk frother so I've got
a pretty pretty All-Star team there
today's rally prediction the greatest
hits with a Sprinkle of more disrespect
to gun violence victims yeah more or
less
more or less what I'm expecting roughly
right I mean
hard to say exactly but that's roughly
what I'm uh what I'm expecting
uh thank you so much to Brent baytel
for gifting a membership at
joinpakman.com also thank you to Anna
Evans and demelza Pasco who just got
themselves memberships putting us at 51.
um it doesn't take long no it really
doesn't take long to sign up you go to
joinpakman.com okay you pick monthly or
yearly yearly is a better deal
but monthly is just humiliatingly
inexpensive but you know whichever one
you pick you type in your coupon code
you know the coupon code could be Obama
Obama that's one coupon code or you
could use sad Trump that's another
coupon code oh that one's even better
I think we actually have an old coupon
code
no more let me see
oh it's invalid oh I could have sworn
that was a coupon code at least at one
point guess that one's done that's sad
actually I kind of like that coupon code
it was a good one there's been a handful
of shootings at gun shows even a child
killed himself in Massachusetts a few
years ago in accident that's horrifying
that's absolutely horrifying if true
I have not independently confirmed that
few other bonuses oh here's the Eggman
calling in about Herschel Walker
hey Dave Herschel Walker is completely
nuts absolutely insane has no business
in government politics at all but he
will win because of one thing name
recognition that's it and that should
also teach us show us who votes the
people that recognize personal Walker
and want that name in government are old
white men that watched football in the
70s and 80s that's it you know it's so
funny what the Eggman says
um about just like old white dudes
liking football players there are a
bunch of different legal conferences
that I've gone to
and often the the guest speakers are
retired football players and I've asked
like what's the connection
is it that you know uh skills that are
relevant on the football field are
relevant to lawyer stuff and the
organizers go
these old white lawyers just love
football players they just love it
they just love it that's that's all it
is
um so that's pretty uh
that that's pretty interesting I have to
say
um okay let's see what else we've got
here
okay so here's a trump supporter I asked
can you just admit that Trump failed on
the wall
absolutely he was challenged from the
Democrats and opposed from them he was
opposed from the same party that while
Obama in office wanted a wall uh that's
a cop-out
that's a total cop-out
um
but okay I mean at least you're saying
the wall wasn't built
that's something
uh
okay uh Eggman with one more voicemail
hey Dave I tried to wait a little bit to
ask you this so it wasn't so sensitive
did you watch the TV show CHiPs when you
were a kid because when discussing the
Texas shooting and the Texas Ranger guy
named Eric Estrada when you mentioned
his name officer Eric Estrada you
hesitated for one second I did which to
me shows me that you know Eric Estrada
the actor prince in ships a cop also
um anyway Shalom brother yeah no I did
and that that was deliberate I mean I
was aware that the uh yeah
no I I definitely was sort of pausing
meaningfully when I mentioned the name
Eric Estrada that's absolutely true
absolutely true
hey David this is just my opinion but if
you look into Donald Trump and all his
deregulations and his trade bans like
usmca if you look into that and you look
into the deregulations and you'll figure
out why you know that in 2022 there was
less recalls than any years before there
was only 32 recalls so far okay I don't
know I just can't comment meaningfully
meaningfully about that
um here's an epidemiologist who called
in
hi David this is long time listener John
from New York City I just wanted to say
thank you for the work you do every day
I'm an epidemiologist and a chief
analytics officer at a large Healthcare
System for the underserved in New York
and watching your shows got me through
the horrors of the height of covid and
the Trump Administration
I I especially appreciate your value of
Truth and accuracy of language I just
wanted to say thank you for shining the
light on the hypocrisy and praisins
criminality of the previous
administration and I'll see you on trout
Central
right truth essential absolutely it is a
beautiful beautiful place yeah no
question about it
um okay very very good important stuff
coming in there
um thanks to Emily Siegel and the
stoning band for the YouTube
subscriptions uh Donald Trump is now 18
minutes late expected
absolutely any moment
um
I mean you know he's 20 minutes late
which isn't that bad but he also hasn't
been he hasn't started speaking yet
uh okay
let's see what else we've got here
Walker doesn't have to have a functional
brain to get Republican Party Support he
just has to do and vote as he's told and
he's their guy yeah more or less I mean
I don't think that's unique to Walker to
Herschel Walker by the way
welcome to Enigma gray the latest twitch
Prime subscriber you are number 52 I
very much yeah right Trump was two and a
half hours late yesterday 20 minutes is
absolutely nothing I mean it's just it's
it's nothing at all
nothing at all
um is there a funnier coupon code I
could offer you know what let me look at
let me look at the old coupon codes just
to see if we can revive one
I'll put a funnier coupon code up there
I don't even remember we just let a lot
of the coupon codes remain active
let's see what we can find I think there
were some pretty funny ones in the early
days of coupon codes I'm probably going
to um
remind myself
of some of them let's see here
uh coupons let's see what old coupon
codes we have
uh
oh boy there are a lot of them here
man that's
that's actually different difficult oh
because the gifting generates a bunch of
coupon codes oh man all right let me see
here uh let's go to
see if I can do this
what's a funny coupon code
there's a there's Jenga coupon code from
we were playing Jenga on the show
golf related
Turtle time does anybody have any idea
what turtle time as a coupon code was
about I don't even remember that does it
relate to Mitch McConnell does anybody
have any memory of when we use the code
Turtle time
it was related to McConnell
okay here's Trump the Trump supporter
with a with another question one
question if I may what promise
apostrophe s have the Dems made and
fulfilled after 60 years why is it
Democrat States never flourish
uh
uh have you have you looked at economic
data
if you rank states by income
it's all blue States at the Top If You
rank states by education quality it's
all blue States at the Top If You rank
states by access to health care it's all
blue States at the Top If You rank
states by a business environment it's
all blue States at the top see this is
the problem
where are you even getting that
it's the blue states that overwhelmingly
subsidize the red States a red State
country
oh it's funny people saying California
doesn't flourish California has an
overwhelming share of all of the most
profitable corporations California has a
surplus yes California has poor people
too
it's it's more populated than most
countries in the world and the reason
California is so expensive is because
there's so much demand to live there I
mean this is like this is not crazy
stuff you know
yes there's video there's homeless
people that's true
that's true
man that's that's like very very dumb
I'm sorry that's very very dumb thank
you to black white Rook for the twitch
Prime subscription you're number 53. I
also want to say thanks to Kevin Combs
and Annelise for gifting to
subscriptions on my website your number
is 54 and 55 today
do you know that Meme where the kid
starts asking a question and his words
get jumbled and the smiles that's
Herschel Walker I haven't seen that one
David sir good job on Herschel Walker he
was a dumb football player and hasn't
gotten any brighter since
blue states have carried red States for
Generations yeah see there's a lot of
people who just don't know anything
and it makes it tough it makes it really
really tough
um okay
someone says David in all seriousness
your website is down and I can't sign up
I I highly doubt that let me see here
let me refresh
the guys the website's working
completely fine
let me see Turtle time
Turtle time
yeah it still works oh wow that's a good
discount I didn't even remember that one
Turtle time I'm almost positive it has
to do with Mitch McConnell it must
it must have to do with Mitch McConnell
uh okay
one other voicemail let's listen
did you know
the
this is Dave from California yes that
Abbott Cruz
and Republicans
have I give up attitude
when it comes to gun control
because nothing they will do
will stop mass shootings
they have a loser's attitude
they have brainstorm this problem
they actually have given up
let's give everybody guns and sooner or
later
somebody is going to shoot the mass
shooter oh my God
all right who's coming out now
[Music]
it's all still pretty toxic oh is this
uh I I don't honestly guys I don't know
who the hell this is my guess is is this
the woman running against Liz Cheney is
that what's going on here
yeah I have no clue I genuinely have no
idea who that is
she must be I mean I I think ostensibly
that's the point of this rally thank you
to Julianne Verrett for signing up at
joinpakman.com Julianne your new member
number 56 today we love your support and
genuinely appreciate it also thanks to
Izzy tone bone for the twitch Prime
subscription
uh let's listen to another voicemail
here
I called in earlier left a voicemail
about
how that Commander didn't make that call
it was above it was above him and how
you know
they never they they kill all um
police if they've breached it and okay
all right it seems like there was
probably some confusion there hey David
long time Watcher of the show and bonus
show I just wanted to ask what's your
favorite thing activity to do in New
York just go to restaurants
honestly I just I barely do anything
else
I walk around and go to restaurants
is there I mean like what am I gonna do
go to a movie theater
that's really dangerous movie theaters
no I mean I just I don't know
I really don't do uh
I really don't do too much else Eric
Clark has signed up with the coupon code
Turtle time and his new member number 57
today 57 which I very much appreciate
um yeah well let's listen to like a
minute of this great and my extended
family is now raising our sixth
generation in this state
[Applause]
as an attorney I have been fighting the
federal government an unelected
bureaucrats for decades
I've been representing those people and
businesses who put food on your table
gas in your car a roof over your heads
and they pave your highways
I have been fighting for you and winning
against the Environmental Protection
Agency
here's this Trump supporter continuing
to argue with me you just made my point
no I didn't you said that blue states
don't flourish and I said yes they do in
every metric blue states do better than
red States and now he says thanks
California reports the highest income
yet it always raises taxes yet housing
issue you make no sense you you don't
understand anything Sir with all due
respect you don't understand basic
economics you don't understand you don't
understand anything I just don't even
know how we can this is sort of like
what we were talking about with a number
of different experts this week
you may be trolling I don't know but um
yeah
I was on holiday in New York in 2018 I
don't recommend going to a baseball game
at the height of Summer go around Autumn
yeah last time I was in Yankee Stadium
it was like five years ago and I think
it was May
and it was uh nice but when it gets too
hot it's not really for me Brianna
Cochrane has just signed up at
joinpakman.com and his new member number
59 also Brianne Cochrane has gifted a
membership and that's number 60 which I
very much appreciate
um
yeah we're at Trump's speaking any
moment and I don't think it's going to
be great I mean slum congressional seat
from that Virginian who currently holds
it
I have driven over 23 000 miles around
Wyoming since announced that I was
running for congress and there has been
one overriding three theme that I have
heard over and over and over again and
that is we're fed up
we're fed up with the federal government
that doesn't seem to work for us anymore
we're fed up without a control spending
and we're fed up with the radical Biden
agenda
the yeah what agenda is that again
[Applause]
we're fed up
maybe formula for their newborns we're
fed up with six dollar gasoline and six
dollar diesel we're fed up with a
shortage of fertilizer for our farmers
and with the supply chain that has been
broken by the incompetence of our
federal agencies
in short we're fed up with inflation and
all of the related monetary policies
that are threatening to turn the
greatest country on earth into a third
world failure
is this kid's presence here child abuse
can anybody weigh in on that
um
thanks to Elizabeth stoffer who just
gifted a subscription at joinpakman.com
and his new member number 61 today
um I am not enjoying listening to
this woman I have to tell you it's not
it's not enjoyable
David sir why is no one calling Marjorie
Taylor green a rhino for not standing by
her convictions in her testimony
um yeah I mean just uh they're they're
not going to do that it's a bit of a bit
of a different situation
they don't they don't see it that way I
think is the the way they would say it
um let's see here is it I'm watching the
uh trumpet NRA a little bit disappointed
for the first time a little bit
disappointed in your uh
your analysis because you could see
Trump is going from one teleprompter to
the other back and forth and he's
literally just reading you could tell he
did not write this it's not his word
he's oh Trump hasn't written any of his
speeches it's not a unique Insight that
Trump didn't write yesterday's speech
Trump trump doesn't write Trump doesn't
read
he hasn't read a book in his entire
adult life of course the of course
someone else wrote the speech
that's not a that's not a big shock I
have to tell you
uh I wanna uh oh whoa we've got a huge
dump of memberships Happening Here
Stephen Norvell Jr just signed up and
Camille Lutz just signed up new members
62 and 63. we I jokingly mentioned that
we have this old coupon code Turtle time
that's still working and I don't even
remember what it's from it might be from
Mitch McConnell uh it's like two years
old anyway I'll put it up here if people
want to use it I don't care what coupon
code people use it's fine with me
uh David there is someone in the chat
called long shot Louie saying you are
afraid of trolls I recommend a hammer
band
um long shot
let's see long shot Louie look at the
groomed kids
none of the speeches
long shot Louie doesn't seem to be
saying anything inappropriate that I can
see
no I think long shot Louie's okay right
now
we'll keep an eye out on it but I think
it's okay
she's fed up but didn't virtually all
Republicans vote against cheaper gas and
more safe formula yes they did
they were all very very much against it
for strange kind of weird reasons
thanks to Blueberry babe and Robert E
for the twitch Prime subscriptions I
appreciate that also big thank you to I
I don't know how to pronounce this last
name
it's Holly dorges
is I hope that that's correct thank you
Holly for signing up on my website your
new member number 66.
I it's starting to get a little dicey
with some last names that I'm not I
don't have a sense I'm correctly
pronouncing them
um
more on Herschel Walker hey Mr Pacman I
have to call back oh this is this is
Troy York
I hate to make another call but
um once again your propaganda your whole
life
um Herschel Walker doesn't have to
answer some hit reporters question no he
doesn't have to answer questions but
when he speaks it's completely
incoherent he could not answer the
questions in a way that's coherent
and I think that's the uh I think that's
the point that a lot of these people
seem to be completely missing
um thanks to the Mob father for the
twitch Prime subscription uh let's
listen to a little bit more of Harriet
hagaman
[Applause]
we're fed up with those types of
Republicans who work harder to deflect
attention from the failures of the
current Administration then they work to
protect us from it
and we're fed up with Liz Cheney
wow
you deserve a representative who knows
what it means to ride for the brand
someone who will fight for you and for
Wyoming someone who will fight for our
constitutional republic someone who will
work tirelessly to roll back the
explosion of bone crushing regulations
and dictats coming out of DC
dicktats jeez that's aggressive
um there's been like almost no
meaningful change to regulation under
Joe Biden uh is that like is that a
penis tattoo is that what that means
I don't know what that was about
I guess it can be pronounced that way
wow dictate
they can be pronounced dick I guess
dictat is valid is that possible no oh
no it's not hold on
dictate yeah okay it's not valid if it's
not valid
well
well that was really weird that was a
weird moment
very very strange
uh this PSA don't ever offer to house
sit I broke so many things I don't think
I'm going to keep any money
all right good advice the flusher on my
toilet broke now even flushing 10 to 15
times won't get rid of the documents hmm
that's interesting
neurodivergent woolly has just signed up
at joinpakman.com which I very much
appreciate uh sorry via twitch Prime
Thomas Cook signed up at joinpakman.com
and Sean Kenner just gifted a
subscription at joinpakman.com I really
appreciate that puts us at 71.
this woman is very unhinged
[Applause]
[Music]
let's just say I mean that's an
impressive list of what we're fed up
about I think that you and I looked at
each other about 50 times because we
have we're both acknowledging with our
eyes that we have never seen a crowd so
fired up before well she went down her
speech saw every life one of the most
simple speeches ever too fed up with
fill the Blake we're fed up with fill
the blank yeah very very um yeah
very very rudimentary technique but it
certainly did seem to work on that crowd
that's I will I will concede that
I will concede that for sure
hey David
um love yourself first time caller just
calling in to say that
um this whole gun control debacle is
giving me major nightmares for future
things that may be even more important
to human life like
climate control and so I'm you know not
to spiral off too much but I'm just
having
because it's almost flashed forward in
the future to
you know when we're we're I mean we're
basically at the Tipping Point already
so when it gets to the point of you know
no hope if we can't even get gun control
past the sleeve like children's lives I
I don't know like I'm the the most
recent climate uh yeah I know all of
that stuff is very very serious and and
we do have to consider all of it
um Trump running about 38 minutes late
so far unexpected
um any moment here
okay that PSA is still up thank you to
Ruth Baker Ruth just signed up at
joinpakman.com and his new member number
72 today do you think Trump has dictats
asks NH Barracks I I don't know but that
was a bizarre moment of that previous
speech
I've never seen anything like it
salty Sylvester has just signed up via
twitch
are rather gifted a uh twitch
subscription which I appreciate
yeah no I'm noticing a lot of people's
uh emotional state understandably is not
great right now
and it makes sense given everything
that's um
going on
I I totally get it I totally get it a
lot of them exasperation I would say
in um Everybody I've been talking to
lately involved with the show without a
question we've looked at the men out
there they're a little
bit of boys like little little soft toys
and we will bend men
to this woke culture to this globalism
idea this one world order and clearly
this channel is nuts huh
Newsmax is also covering it
is this George Papadopoulos is that who
this is
I think that you know a DC jury uh are
you optimistic that they will look at
this evidence and they will judge
carefully or do you think that they are
completely tainted
unfortunately 96 of DC residents voted
Democrat in the past election and the
Durham team was unable to judge gotta
leave it there great to have you as
always I'm sorry as you know the drill
Saturday night and here we want to
listen and watch as president Donald
Trump takes the stage here in Casper
Wyoming
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank God
40 minutes late Donald Trump has indeed
appeared he is pumping his fists and
throwing hats around
recommendations for dick tat artists I
don't know any I don't know any thanks
to Matt Kinney for signing up at
joinpakman.com your new member number 74
today and I really do appreciate that
um David would love to see an interview
with someone who can talk about the ipcc
report from a few months ago 700 million
displaced people in Africa by the end of
the decade all right we will look into
that
we'll look into that
she's calling men beta boys as the
Village People plays there is no
parodying these people well said
well said
uh yeah
we will see
what uh Trump has for us today
our Wyoming roads are so simple maybe
they made a wrong turn and they headed
to Waltman Wyoming right
that absolutely could have happened but
it does seem that they finally made it
they finally made it
[Music]
it's almost satirical that Queen's born
Trump plays this song at his rallies it
really is
uh welcome to Kevin Williams Kevin just
signed up at joinpakman.com and his new
number member number 75 we really may
get to a hundred today it's it's
completely plausible
that it could happen
it is something else
look at this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Trump's eyes are looking a little bit
less swollen than usual like the right
eye is pretty open today
often times it's completely swollen shut
there's an artist named wanksy who did
Trump's dictat quite skilled actually
man
yeah
wow
thank you very much
water group
ER
thank you very much Wyoming and I'm
thrilled to be back in this Majestic
state with thousands of proud
hard-working American Patriots and you
are hard-working aren't you
in 2020 we won Wyoming by the largest
margin of any state in the nation red or
blue red or blue
this is Maga country this is
in fact they gave us a new name they
made a little mistake with this one this
is ultra Maga country
whoa even better over the next six
months the people of Wyoming are going
to vote to dump your rhino congresswoman
Liz Chaney
thank you
and you're going to send the incredible
Harriet Hageman to Congress and together
we are going to end crazy Nancy Pelosi's
political career once and for all crazy
Nancy she is crazy big massive dumps and
please remember that Nancy Pelosi and
Schumer and Biden and all of these
Democrats are totally against Wyoming
and your great source of wealth the
liquid gold right under your feet it's
called Energy
and they will turn you very rapidly into
a very poor state if you don't do
something so you have to do something I
let it go we really were swinging in
Wyoming we were swinging like never
before they want to close you down so
remember that when you walk into that
Booth right carry it they're going to
remember
and Harry is the exact opposite by the
way Wyoming's already 19th per uh by
income in the United States and even
that's only as high as it is because for
tax purposes there's a bunch of really
rich people that quote live in Wyoming
and Communists right away it looked the
Press hates to say that how could you
say that Lulu you got a lot of press
back there got a lot of press why are
there so many
why oh why are there so many every one
of them say fake news every one of them
only right-wing media covered these
events
in many ways
worse than the
terrible Democrats are the backstabbing
Rhino Republicans who are helping them
do their act
and there is no rhino in America who is
thrown in her lot with the radical left
more than Liz Cheney
[Music]
[Applause]
she has gone crazy
now I get it I've been hearing all these
stories for years now she's crazy she's
essentially a trumpist who voted 90 with
Trump but she does think Trump genuinely
lost
[Music]
but people aren't buying the yak based
on the polls she's way down she's at a
level that nobody's seen yet so we'll
see what happens
get out and vote don't let those
Democrats vote for you don't let them
vote you know you got a crazy system
here you know what that means right
don't let the Democrats do what they did
at another state last week
don't let them do it because the
Democrats get in by the way lieutenant
governor
of Georgia we just had a great primary
Victory today a nicely endorsed
candidate
you know that no no mention of David
Perdue and Herschel Walker
okay
commercial Walker who can barely speak
[Applause]
we swept this is just this last week
33-0 in Texas we swept Arkansas in fact
we have a great new governor going to
take place very soon in Arkansas right
we know who that is right
Sarah Huckabee Sanders she's great
and
and we are sweeping we're sweeping
everything global-ish and we actually
did great in Georgia those races all the
congressmen and Congress people we swept
everything so a couple of little
problems we had with a lot of people
voting and uh you have to be very very
careful it was a big problem people
voted and it caused Trump a major
problem rats to vote in a Republican
primary you know the governor was very
nice he met me at the plane but I said
Governor you shouldn't allow Democrats
to vote in a Republican primary he was
very very nice
uh Kemp didn't beat Purdue because of
Democrats voting in that primary it was
a blowout I'd rather have Democrats not
voting in the Republican
I don't need hats
I don't need the Hat
Wyoming thought you were electing a
conservative Warrior but instead you got
a lap dog for Pelosi and a human sound
bite machine for CNN and
msdnc Ms DNC oh yeah yeah that's a good
one
Liz Cheney hates the voters of the
Republican party and she has for longer
than you would know Wyoming deserves a
congresswoman who stands up for you and
your values not one who spends all of
her time putting you down going after
your president in the most vicious way
your president loving endless
nonsensical bloody horrible Wars that
never end they just never end the janies
are die-hard globalists and warmongers
who have been plunging us into new
conflicts for decades spilling American
blood and spending American treasure all
over the world the Chinese along with
George Bush didn't even have the courage
to Pardon scooter Libby he was that big
protector you know he protected George
Bush very badly he could have been in
big trouble and so could Cheney and they
didn't do it you know who did it I did
it I gave him a party
got something to care about
scooter Libby right I gave scooter Libby
a pardon they couldn't do it they
wouldn't do it or they couldn't do it
and uh I thought it was a terrible thing
but I gave scooter Libby because scooter
Libby got screwed okay and I didn't do
it for them I did it because I thought
it was the right thing to do and frankly
George but the crowd really identifies
with Trump pardoning of Elites
they didn't like that's why Liz Cheney
voted no one bringing our troops back
home from Syria where they didn't even
want to have us
I mean it's so crazy we go to countries
that don't even want us so we just go
there it's almost like we do it by habit
we do it by habit but we lose people
cost very much money but we lose people
which is much more important and much
worse and that's why
Liz Cheney now is at the front of the
parade trying to get us to go into Wars
with Russia or anyone else that wants to
bite anyone can you see that and you see
it all over and you see it over and over
the stupidity of these people and you
know when I was there we were respected
nobody was going to war with us that's
very much
[Applause]
we didn't have to go to war for people
to know that we were the toughest and we
were the strongest we did it
in a much different way
she's the face of the Washington swamp
and the same failed foreign policy of
the clintons bushes the Obamas the
bidens Obama and the entire sick
political establishment
okay
I think she looks good
Works nice
[Applause]
but Liz Chaney is about America last
she's weak on border security by the way
very weak on border security and his
house conference chair she sent every
Republican member of Congress talking
points on amnesty ripped word for word
from the anybody know if this kid's okay
right here
very very strange behavior from this guy
[Music]
oh Trump pointing at that kid now wow do
you guys hear Trump just pointed at that
one kid
[Applause]
look at all these people down here all
these press people
Vienna
you saw the ratings after the election
their ratings died
they want us back so badly they want us
I actually thought they were going to
endorse me every one of them
if you're anyone more self-centered
history of personally caused more damage
and destruction to our Republic than the
thinking
ridiculous and stupid thinking of Liz
Cheney she's aided and abetted the
radical Democrat Party in one of the
most unhinged Lawless and dangerous
witch hunts of all time the unselect
committee
on January 6th
and I see these guys
just like they did Russia Russia Russia
same group
now they're talking oh Insurrection that
they don't mention what they did to
Portland and burning down Federal
courthouses and all other things
but this is the same group Adam
Shifty shift
he stands up this is a terrible thing
for our nation same exact words
and that turned out to be a hoax and I
have to congratulate
Mr Durham that turned out to be a total
focus
nobody has any idea what's going on
I wish you did it before the election it
would have been nice but you know what
we got 12 million more votes this time
that we got last time we did much better
the second time that we did the first
time but I still wish they did it before
the election
but as one of the nation's leading
proponents of the Insurrection hoax Liz
Cheney has pushed a grotesquely false
fabricated and hysterical well I didn't
realize he was calling the Insurrection
a hoax is that is that new which has
become the pretext for the most chilling
assault on your civil liberties in
Generations look what they're doing to
these people
look what they're doing to these people
and yet antifa and BLM they can do
whatever the hell they want they can
steal money and live in six million
dollar mansions and nobody does a damn
thing
[Applause]
they can kill people and nobody does
anything and they've killed plenty who
has black lives matter killed or antifia
that I actually don't know about
construction that they've caused and
nobody does a thing about it
and now you look at the so-called word
Insurrection January 6 what a lot of
crap what a lot of crap
and most of this country knows it and
you know who else knows that the
Democrats it's another con job just like
Russia Russia Russia this was made up by
Hillary Clinton and the Democrats a
total fake story
and they have another fake Story coming
it's the answer and many others
I mean don't forget
I've been investigated more than Billy
the Kid
Jesse James
and the great legendary mobster Alphonse
Capone did everything I've had more
investigations than Jesse James
taking the cake for investigations a
friend of mine said you know this has
been going on for years you must be the
most this is a lie because Trump doesn't
have friends
it's been going on today
16
but because of what Liz Journey did
that's why she was thrown out of the
house Republican leadership which is
just about a first
it's why she was censured by the
Republican National Committee which is
something that virtually never happens
it's why she was censured by the Wyoming
GOP I love the Wyoming
I love the Wyoming GOP
and we have Frank here I'll introduce
him but I'm very proud of Frank
and it's why in two months from now the
people of Wyoming are going to tell her
Liz you're fired get out of here get out
of here
throwing the hell out of here
throw him the hell out of here
you're fired
get the hell out of here
let us shady has helped the radical
Democrat Party weaponize the National
Security State in law enforcement
against Mega and Maga supporters who are
hard-working incredible people they try
and
he's going Ultra Magna please
[Applause]
remember Hillary with that little speech
she made where she brought up a word
right remember the word and who what if
I would have thought right who would
have ever thought that word was going to
be was going to go down in infamy she
said
a few words that we won't repeat because
we have a whole new narrative right what
[Applause]
the phony narrative that Liz Cheney is
pushing has been the radical left spree
text for their all-out
war on Free Speech
the persecution of the January 6
political prisoners you know you still
have a lot of them in jail
how many people from antifa are still in
jail how many people from black lives
matter are still in jail
how many people that have killed people
are still in jail
the Democrat crusade to gut election
Integrity is something that nobody has
ever seen anything like it in this
country
Wyoming all of America is counting on
you so important do you become we all
know how great a state you are how
beautiful you are
but you've become
politically speaking you're at the top
of the list you have a big we have a lot
of elections coming up for senators and
for Governors anybody have any idea what
this is about important election
election that we have right here
nobody knows okay and you're going to
have it from within you're going to get
hit from within like you've never been
hit because they want to win it and I
hate to say this Harriet but they want
to win it because they want to hurt
Trump
stay here so at least you can feel good
about yourself
they want to hurt you that's all they
care about
you know
[Applause]
[Music]
when you went over a hundred races and
all they want to talk about is One race
which was relatively unimportant
compared to some that's all they want to
talk about I said will they ever talk
about the great evening so all they want
to do is that but you're strong and you
know she's one of the greatest lawyers
and I got to witness her speaking just a
few minutes ago and man you're good
Harrier
nobody's gonna take you come on up here
please
but we need you to vote that crazy Rhino
and that's what she's become Beyond
anybody's expectation
out of office got to get her out of
office and
Beyond one vote you know this is a
symbol it's much more important than one
vote this is a symbol you gotta win you
gotta win otherwise it's going to be
a terrible thing for our country and
it's not just the one vote because I
think the Republicans are going to have
a tremendous midterm especially in the
house especially in that we'll see
so
it's not it's looking as bad as it has
in the last year for Republicans it's
still not looking terrible but it's not
looking nearly as good as it was
with Liz Cheney's support the unselect
committee has turned the United States
House of Representatives into an
instrument of political torment and
repression you know that you see that
every night
and people come out of the witness booth
and they'll say the worst of all the
people and you have some really bad
people up there as Democrats the worst
person of all was Liz Cheney these are
people like you these are people that
represent our interest at the same time
she's helping to completely cover up and
do numbers on the disturbing questions
and videos you take a look at what they
do who was picking their nose I could I
didn't notice that
it was not just every time they give us
a certain video from a certain little we
want
the real videos I don't really know what
happened and more importantly we want to
know what the hell happened to the
election itself
which is the reason they were down there
Cheney and the unselect committee are
also totally ignoring the very real
concerns about Capital Security failures
and why is an example Nancy Pelosi
rejected ten thousand National Guard
troops or soldiers and I strongly
recommend it and the fakers back here
never remember Trump resisted allowing
in the National Guard on January 6 for
hours
but you know we recommended the
Secretary of Defense through me
but we recommended ten thousand and some
people said ten thousand plus but you
didn't need ten thousand you needed five
hundred or a thousand but recommended
ten thousand because I felt this is on
January 3rd I felt that the crowd was
going to be massive everybody was saying
we're going to be there I believe it was
the largest crowd I've ever spoken
before anybody that was there would say
the same thing they never want to show
that crowd they never want to talk about
this it's bigger than the Million Man
March he's bragging about the crowd that
ultimately went to the Capitol and
committed hundreds of crimes if not
thousands in my opinion before a crowd
that big and nobody wants to talk about
it from the fake news media despite
having pushed every anti-republican fake
news conspiracy theory under the sun
from the Russia bounties remember the
Russian bounties remember that that
turned out to be a fake that was another
hoax then you had the double impeachment
hoax a perfect phone call remember it's
a perfect call remember remember they
called
the president of Ukraine and they asked
him Mr President what did you think he
did nothing wrong what are you talking
about that's why I like them that's why
I like them but he did nothing wrong he
said they were devastated they didn't
want to put that out
with that being said by the way that war
should have never ever happened it would
have never happened under me
and there can be no winners
that country is being blown to pieces
people are being killed at a level that
nobody's ever seen none of us have ever
seen anything like it and it's a
terrible thing and you're not going to
have any winners it's something they
ought to get back to the table that
would have never happened it should have
never ever happened should have never
ever ever happened and it would have
never happened sleepy eyes Chuck Todd
from NBC was interviewing
the Secretary of State and he said to
him let me ask you a question how come
this never happened by the way and I re
I really respect Chuck for saying this
but he said why did this never happen
under the Trump Administration
right
remember uh under Bush
they lost Georgia
I'm not talking about our churches that
we love so much I'm talking about a
different Georgia uh country under Bush
they lost Georgia and then under Obama
they lost Crimea
[Music]
lost everything everything
and under Trump they lost nothing
nothing
they lost nothing under Trump
same thing with China do you notice they
have these wasn't there like a major uh
occupation of the Donetsk and luhansk
regions under Trump
and I had a talk with
presidency of China I had a talk with
President Putin Russia
and they said you can't do it it was
almost the same answer I said we're
going to hit you very hard if you do it
and both of them said why really and you
know I'm not sure they believed me but
they sort of believe me they didn't have
to believe me full
if they believe me five percent that was
enough right right Harriet all they had
to do but I will tell you it was zero
chance and zero chance of China let's
see what China does I mean the only
thing that's keeping China out
is they see how poorly Russia is doing
but Russia now has a different tactic
they stay way far away and they just
keep lobbing missiles and missiles and
missiles into these cities and these
poor people that are being decimated and
you're going to end up with nothing
going to end up with nothing that whole
country is being obliterated and you'll
end up with millions of lives and you
made it may end up with a third world
war by the way okay you may end up with
a third world war because of the
stupidity of what we're saying and what
we're doing and we want to help the
people because what's happening to them
they're being a crowd seems very bored
we could end up in a third world war
because of the way we're going about it
and I never thought that would be
possible and the third world war would
be like no other War because the third
world war we have weaponry right now I
completely rebuilt the United States
military and in rebuilding it
in rebuilding it
and in rebuilding it we also rebuilt
renovated and brand new nuclear weapons
and I hated to do it because I saw the
power I know the power better than
anybody I know the power and we are in a
position that I never thought we'd be in
we have a major country every day he
mentions nuclear nuclear nuclear and
China's doing things that they would
have never done with us we're in a
position now I don't think our country
has ever been in a worse position in a
weaker position a more pathetic position
and a lot of it so you know I can think
of many times that we have from
Afghanistan
second uh Iraq War
Vietnam
ring a bell still in political history
which is now finally being proven in
court crooked Hillary Clinton and the
Democrats spied on my campaign and they
spied on my White House
they spied on me when I was in the Oval
Office could you imagine if a republican
got caught spying on President Biden
bident
wouldn't be too exciting
spying on Obama spying could you imagine
you're spying on President Obama Obama's
lying on President Obama from the
outside and you get caught
I think it would be at a minimum the
rest of your life in the who's gal
and maybe stronger than that and they
don't even talk about it we caught them
spying on our campaign we have it
absolute proof none of that is true I
hope people know I remember a long time
ago when Twitter was good now it's going
down the tubes by the way when he was on
it it was good right we want Trump ready
truth social true social
truth
Truth uh their heads are spinning that
one's going so well everybody get off
Twitter and go truth social you did good
I did too
mine was enforced but they want me back
for the media they want me back so badly
and I'm not going back because we have
truth we have truth on our side that's
the way I look at it we have truth on
our side
get off Twitter
but you remember I put out like this
tweet I think it was like on a Saturday
morning and I saw something on
television and I said
I believe Obama
spied
on my campaign okay
now I didn't think it was that big a
deal you know you put it ahead on a ball
three minutes later I get a call like my
phone goes crazy
did you just say that sorry sir
President Obama
after Kofi it was the single biggest
tweet I ever did
confetti was bigger
but after kofefi which was world's
number one
it was the biggest tweet I ever did and
I thought it was just going to be like
routine you know him throwing it out but
that's what I thought that's the routine
and you know why it was such a big deal
because it was idiotic we caught them
and they realized that we caught them
and it became a monster we need kofefi
on the soundboard connected and in the
end it may be years later but now it's
turned out to be true
and just remember if a republican did it
it would be perhaps the death penalty
right yeah there you go
if Biden tweeted kofefi they would they
would uh execute them you know we hit a
nerve let's put it that way we seriously
hit a nerve I kept saying I can't
believe this is such I was getting calls
sir this thing is blowing up the
machines were on fire
Hillary Clinton's former campaign
manager real Beauty Robbie Mook recently
testified that the russia-russia Russia
hoax
this is two and a half years of crap wow
two and a half years we all went through
and we put our country in danger just so
you know
was conducted with the knowledge and
approval of crooked Hillary Clinton
herself
she's guilty
as you can be now the real question now
is whether Durham will have the courage
and I hope he does to expose the
corruption of the Mueller Witch Hunt and
the Hillary Clinton disaster with all of
the stuff that they released the whole
thing was a hoax and think of it they
knew it was a hoax and they went two and
a half years the country spent 48
million dollars or so they had FBI
agents all over the place they had 18
angry Democrats as prosecutors this went
on for years and yet think of it this
way because I have to brag with all of
that going on I'm under investigation in
a phony situation people said this is
delusional I'm probably gonna bear I I
doubt I'm covering this entire speech
the way it's going uh you know it also
started 45 minutes late let's just see
how far we can get evident thing to do
with Russia no
no not at I thought it was a very
interesting question right then a month
later they'd come up Harriet I needed
you as my lawyer they said
he said sir did you have anything to do
with Russian young kids would come up I
said no why are they ask you this
question about Russia what the hell do I
have to do with Russia and about four or
five times more they come up and then
after about the fifth time an innocent
young man sir hi sir that's right sir
sir
do you know anything about Russia
and I said this is this is this is one
of the worst I've ever seen what is
going on with Russia so they created a
fake story
and I didn't take it seriously because I
do there was nothing to it
we've endorsed JP right JD Mandel
because it's fake
and two and a half years later I was
right after we went through hell and
despite going through hell we did more
than perhaps any but just about more
than any president in the history of our
country
thank you and you went through it with
us I mean you went through a lot of
people were affected and a lot of people
believed it a lot of people believed it
you know they keep hearing it every day
it started off as a statement by
somebody about somebody situation where
they asked Robbie Mook Robbie Mook
little Robbie hi Robbie how you doing
and
do you think this was Russia you know I
think it was
that terrible terrible reporter who got
thrown over to CNN Chris Wallace who
always wanted to be Mike but he didn't
have the talent
Chris Wallace he wanted to be Mike you
know Mike did me on 60 Minutes and Mike
was a killer but he gave me a great
piece and to 60 Minutes years
Mike did me on 60 Minutes by giving me a
great piece geez I think as I remembered
Chris Wallace as Robbie Mook a question
does Trump have anything to do with
Russia
Robbie Luke was like you know John
Lovett's the liar remember when Saturday
night used to be good it is so pathetic
now
it's so bad but remember John love it
there's like fractally branching topics
here man that's right I'm a businessman
oh
that's right I'm a business I went to
the Wharton School of Finance that's
right I went to the worm school yeah I'm
a great success remember John love it's
a liar this was Robbie Mook he said
about Russia and Robbie mucus
yeah yeah
Russia Russia
and I'm telling you I was watching this
all right guys I'm bailing out I I just
can't do any more of this this was this
is one of the worst ever
um and it's going absolutely nowhere I
think we get it I think we get it the
crowd's unhinged Trump's unhinged this
is just it I I think I think we're gonna
just put an end to it right now
um appreciate you joining me
I think our brains will rot if we
continue uh if you want to keep watching
it watch it on Newsmax watch it on right
side broadcasting but I think I'm gonna
bail out um for my own mental health
okay yeah people we're people are we're
hemorrhaging viewers already
so um listen do yourselves a favor
do anything other than watching this
okay it's it's just it's too toxic at
this point in time we'll see everybody
very soon we've got a lot going on next
week have a great Memorial Day okay yeah
I know people are thanking me you could
have got asked for a mercy ban as well
if you needed one
but uh
it's too obscene and stupid exactly all
right everybody have a good night see
you soon